the Joe Rogan experience did you see
that Canada banned assault weapons they
banned all salt weapons there's like a
two-year grace period you got like two
years and you got to turn in your ar-15
that is not making the the gun people
here happy very very upset and people
are pointing something out to these
really connait a video of a Canadian
sheriff discussing it and he said out of
all the shootings that I've ever been a
part of where there's illegal activity
like that and horrible crimes that are
being committed he goes it's never with
a licensed gun over the these aren't
licensed gun owners these people that
got these guns they're gonna get these
guns illegally anyway just because
they're not legal doesn't mean they're
not they're gonna do an illegal thing
they don't need a legal gun to do an
illegal thing and if you think that
something all you're going to do is make
it more difficult and more money for the
gun runner's it's gonna for sure it's
gonna be something where it's more risky
for them but it's also gonna be more
profitable it's gonna be hard to get a
gun over there but people are still
gonna do it they bring coke in from
South America they're gonna bring guns
into Canada it's gonna happen but only
the criminals are gonna happen now yeah
getting an illegal assault weapon is the
nicest thing anybody getting an assault
weapons doing yes exactly perfectly put
that's exactly what it is it's just I
wish there was a world where we didn't
need guns I wish for sure but that's not
this world doesn't mean you don't love
people this means like you gotta look at
things practically you can't look at
things the way you want them to be you
got to look at things the way they are
the way they are is there's more guns
and there are people and to say you
can't have a gun anymore it's like okay
well who gets to give a gun and who's
gonna take the guns away and what are we
gonna do about the Constitution and why
when can we vote on this or should this
be a part of the Bill of Rights where
this is how we are and this is how this
country was established this is the
things we agree on we don't want to vote
on whether or not we have free speech we
need free speech should we vote on
whether or not we have the Second
Amendment some people say no some people
say what we're dealing with is a mental
health problem and we're not dealing
with a gun problem the gun problem is
that the mentally ill people get the
guns it's not a gun problem
there's a lot of people that want to
have guns to protect themselves from
mentally ill people that are violent and
it's also the news again there's a lot
of this goes back to news for me mm-hmm
and them glorifying these people this is
what they say you know what I mean they
know they're gonna get the coverage they
know that their names gonna get out
there you know it's not it's not
acceptable if we didn't do that then
they wouldn't do that much more to me
than the guns if we take away the guns
that we have the guns like if we cover
it differently things will be different
without a doubt it's true but people
want to know what the name of the guy
who shot up the school is they don't get
so now they broadcast that people find
it online I don't think they should why
why would that be necessary I don't know
man I think it's just one of those
things about human nature like if there
was a video of Tom Cruise falling off
the back of a plane you would watch it
if he fell to his death you'd watch that
video wouldn't you well yeah yeah if it
leaks yeah I think it's kind of along
the same lines does that make sense yeah
but I think that I think that the
government could help with that
if they're going to before I think
before restricting guns I think they
could step in and and then maybe run it
by some psychiatrists and scientists and
whatnot and see what they think about
the media part of a crime because again
I mean like these people want to be
legends they want to be mmm
it certainly has an effect it's
certainly other than the fact you know I
watched this this Hitler documentary and
they talked about how Ava Braun this
applies to what we're talking about
I mentioned Eva Braun didn't have to go
to the bunker to die with Hitler and
this person said that she did it because
she knew that by doing that against
Hitler's wishes that she would
inevitably die with Hitler and therefore
because she was kept behind the scenes
and on the backburner so much become a
bigger part of history so she could have
decided to live a normal life maybe get
prosecuted later
whatever but sort of live or go to
prison or whatever or go to the bunker
and die with Hitler and be part of
history forever and be represented as
the woman that was with Hitler
[Applause]